all right and we are
live the last word with law incognito
and ibantis
fresh friday evening campfire
and uh we got a little special guest i
think going on what's going on
yeah well it sounds like you slept in
first off so you were like rested and
good to go the vampire lifestyle
actually actually not doing too shabby
but uh yeah we gotta guess so i gotta
get her introduced so
strap in everybody let's get this thing
going
so welcome to the last word episode 113.
i'm so excited about our guest who is
joining us tonight
long time in the making so let's jump
right in i'd like to introduce a lady
who knows all about role playing games
both digitally
and in person from couch co-op with
friends to twitch streaming on the side
she knows the people around you are
crucial to your experiences both gaming
and life
this is a lady who really dove deep into
video games when destiny got its
hooks in and hasn't looked back since
introducing
the manager director and driving force
behind the scenes of the planet destiny
website
someone who has more creative creativity
in one hand than i may ever have in my
entire life
a renaissance woman who paints sculpts
writes
narrates and more someone whose vault
holds vault of glass in a special place
in her heart and someone who braces all
things witch
everybody let's welcome moonvault to the
podcast
oh my gosh thank you so much for having
me
that was extremely flattering by the way
i was just sitting here like oh
oh just like slowly working up the
octaves of the reaction
yes yes that made me smile thank you so
much
i'm excited to be here yes very good to
have you great to have you how you've
been
bare have you been how's how's you been
how's destiny been
what's going on i have been excellent i
am really enjoying destiny this season
um and you know i'm enjoying the summer
months and just lounging around and
being able to uh to play out everything
that the season has to offer
so nice yeah nice nice speaking of which
he looks like there's been a lot to
offer but we'll get into that
nothing happened zero this week no news
at all uh we definitely got some stuff
to talk about but i wanted to get
started and ask you as i was digging
into a little bit of your background you
told me and
got a couple nuggets so i know i
mentioned the point about you as a
painter but one specific thing came up
from a couple different people so i
definitely have to address it
so when you paint obviously you paint
different things but you actually paint
objects so i want you to kind of
tell us the story of how you started
painting the objects i'll let you i'll
let you tell the story but
i want to know what's your favorite that
you painted and also the biggest that
you painted this will make sense in
about three seconds when she tells you
what they are
the objects that i typically paint are
animal skulls
i live in a state that has a pretty rich
um uh cattle ranching industry
and there's also a lot of sustenance
hunting
that happens up here so you can go to a
local thrift shop
and you can find an animal skull pretty
easily and i thought you know
i came into the possession of a couple
of
bovine skulls like six years ago
and i thought i need to paint these and
i haven't looked back since it's um
something about them is just
really inspiring and really fun to work
with in that medium
so nice what's your
um like do you have a favorite one that
you've done specifically anything that's
like on display in your house
or um actually the ones that are on
display in my house
are not painted funnily enough um
i think my favorite is yet to come i'm
working on a really special one right
now
um and i can already envision it it's
going to be awesome but i am
i've been hanging on to this ram skull
for a long time
and it's it doesn't tie any relation
into the game does it
it doesn't but it does kind of in a way
like the other way around um
if if you want me to talk a little bit
about this i
um i think i answered this in your
questionnaire but i uh
i um originally got into destiny 1
because i
was watching a friend play it and one of
the very many many many things that
interested me about the first
title in the franchise was the armor and
he was playing on his
void lock and he had that ram on and i
was like oh that's
sick let's go so i've i've always loved
the aesthetic of
a good animal skull oh that makes sense
the red oh ram was so classic very
iconic exotic helmet
and then you got the all this edible
skulls i can see it i can see so let me
ask you this though
yeah how we feeling about the stag you
know
i don't like the stag as much
really but i think with the right armor
with the right set
it can look really cool i wish it had a
bit more utility in the game as well i'd
probably use it a little bit
um it's hard to get me to part with like
my geomegs if i'm doing a pda activity
this is real warlock talk i'm loving
this keep continuing continue
just confirming character of choice this
is the lob
character of choice class of choice
are you are you a warlock at heart oh
absolutely 100
making sure it just wanted to clarify
for everybody well you are invited
anytime
that we we i have my sister with me we
good right now we gotta stick together
you know don't mind these titans out
here you know
the hunters like to pick on us it's all
right call us nerds shove us into the
locker
that sort of thing exactly so real quick
question though just going to back you
up
on this tag for a bit oh yeah have you
gotten the stag
ornament though the more ornate one have
you seen that one i have and that one is
quite beautiful um it doesn't have like
the same kind of earth and bone
aesthetic that i'm really fond of with
the stag
um it's more kind of technological
looking but i think
you know it kind of mixes that sort of
uh fantasy sci-fi
element of destiny together really well
so i definitely appreciate the ornament
for sure sounds good
one more warlock question yes all right
gundy your head down oh
yeah rich well that's our subclass
boyd void all the way boyd was what my
friend was when he got me into the game
it's what i started out playing because
i was interested in it
and it's just been part of my identity
as a
guardian for the whole time nova warper
like nem well yeah i am a i i
uh you know it depends um i've been
using devour a lot more lately but i
i used to stick a little bit more to um
i run the gamut of all three you know
and i i i like the other subclasses too
a lot they have awesome a lot of utility
so you said your geo mags those are
always
yeah it's nice you just
that is one exotic i am not as fond of
how they look
um but gosh they're just function over
fashion on that functional
right yeah so good you almost can't play
middle tree without playing why would
you right
yeah it's i remember when i it took me
so long to get them
and i remember i'm like when i finally
got it because i
played without them so long so i just
became used to the super just ending so
fast that's just part of the super
and then i got it i'm like this is
ridiculous
i can totally understand just how the
long how long it lasted but
i feel you on the on the world lock
story you got more questions uh because
i got some stuff too
oh yeah there you go one go man yeah i'm
just gonna say
one thing i also saw about your history
was uh voice
work i want to know if you could talk
about that a little bit just uh
what part of that interests you and any
maybe um
things that you've done um sure yeah i
can start
kind of at the beginning i guess um when
i was in
story time high school i um
dj'd fm radio for a local college
station
um for a couple years and that was
always such a wonderful experience in my
life and um
it's actually also how i came to stream
because streaming broadcasting kind of
filled that void
that was left when i was no longer djing
um and you know obviously if you're on
the radio you have a radio voice
and that was something that i kind of
just fell into over the years
um and more recently
um a lot of people found me through this
and i this is a project i am so grateful
for
and i will never shut up about because i
still cannot believe i was part of it
um but bife last year released a video
about
thorn and the last word and i was
fortunate enough fortunate enough
to be a part of that project as the
voice of jaron ward's ghost and that was
oh i still that is like one of my
crowning achievements in the community
it was so incredible i did not know that
was you i love you
that's so dope wow that was iconic shout
out to buy food we've had by the
campfire
that was an iconic series and i believe
he also used brian
marcus arc which we also had or the last
word
so it's called the last word actually
that video
um the art in that video was uh stephen
i think is his name the russian comic
artist but beif has utilized um
brian montgomery a lot and it's oh
always so good
such talented people in this community
um absolutely that's kind of the thing
like there's
there's so many people in this community
that are talented artists you've got
like the irl guardians so many artists
when you go to guardian con and just
like the amount of artwork that you want
to take home and just like
artists garden con is lit oh it's
every single year it's always so good
and the cosplay that we see too
come out of this community phenomenal um
do you are you familiar with
um uh auram effects
or i don't think so eric newgaard he
makes a lot of the prop weapons for
bungie
like he made um last year he made the
xenophage that was it
if you were there um he's also made uh
some stuff for
employees internally um that they'd love
to post about because they're so
gorgeous but he started out making um
halo armor and also like
early d1 stuff um and i remember
in 2016 i got to go to an rtx
convention that's rooster teeth
convention um
and he was there with at the time
um impact props and he had um
like his full master chief
like um oh what is it called pepakura
armor i don't know if it's actually
peppa curry but it's something like that
milder her forget the villadora
mm-hmm yeah okay and um he also had
an ace of spades and a last word that he
had made himself
completely you know hadn't even been
involved with bungie yet and it was just
so cool to get to see him
it was three years later this last gcx
and just be like i remember you you were
my favorite part of that rtx convention
he was like
whoa he just like couldn't believe that
somebody knew him from back then it was
it was just really cool
that's the point is i'm sorry for
rambling
yeah we open it up we we you're gonna go
off on tangents the entire time
so you are welcome now you're good
you're good you're doing this this is
your time
[Music]
that is awesome that is really cool
that's what's up
so eat what you got yeah so i wanted to
ask you actually as well so
uh when it comes to like gaming you game
not just in the world of like destiny
and things of that nature you do some
real life stuff
so kind of wanted a little tease of like
how you got into just actually playing d
d
and stuff like that as you know a pretty
consistent hobby and stuff one of the
reasons why sometimes we haven't been
able to get you on
because like hey it's d and d night and
we're like hold on yeah
so it's like a little more detail of how
it came into and and it sounds like your
group of friends is
like kind of how you got into destiny as
well so it's like you got a pretty cool
group that you seem to hang around with
so d d came a lot later for me than
destiny did um
actually it i started playing dnd uh my
first dnd campaign ever was when i took
over planet destiny
and i was working from home and i could
kind of make my own schedule so
i've i've mostly played with people
online too i don't really play in real
life a whole lot
okay um but i you know my
group of friends was organizing a
fifth edition module campaign and they
asked me to be part of it and
i've been sucked into several tabletop
rpg situations since because
i have no self-control
and i love creating and i love making
characters and i love exploring
narratives and stories with my friends
that's why i love destiny too you know
it kind of all plays together that way
so nice
that's pretty cool that's really cool
your destiny history is pretty
interesting because
you know you kind of came from a
observer standpoint almost right and
then
kind of got in so it's like through a
friend and stuff like that and i thought
it was
very interesting to see you know someone
get into destiny that way
with kind of a light video game
background i would say i would get my
correct for that no no no it was i was i
was never really a gamer growing up you
know people have these rich beautiful
stories of like
you know i was in diapers and playing my
[ __ ] snakes and like
just i i you know i had that honey as
controller at the
age of five um
but i you know i played
i had a game boy advance i played like
pokemon emerald and then some other
titles that don't bear remembering
really and then i you know
played a couple pc games that were
very light and not super um
pithy i guess you could say uh but then
i always throughout high school loved
watching
my friends play video games if i'd go
and hang out at their house just
live twitching that's all you're doing
yeah just left with before twitch
she was number one in the comment
section
backseat gamer at the best right now
that's what we do
and i have i have really fond memories
of watching my friends play
like silent hill too um
i'm playing like all the metal gear
games and just
that sort of thing uh so i've always
been interested in i and i'm an artist
so i love visual
storytelling right um and i i still felt
like i
i got to experience it watching friends
play
and i still do it sometimes like i i
watch a friend play
death stranding and that was very
interesting um
but i you know destiny was the one that
got me
it was the one that i saw and i was like
i want to do
that and d1 is the place i learned to
use a controller
it's the place jump into the deep end on
that one literally
it was the first time i'd ever played an
fps
um wow despite its kind yeah yeah
and it you know i spent a whole year
between like house of wolves and
i guess kind of sort of well maybe not a
whole year but kind of
house of wolves to taken king i sort of
just
all i wanted to do in d1 was drive
around on my sparrow and do patrols
because you know it was just this new
beautiful thing that i've never
experienced before and
getting to learn very slowly how to
teach myself how to
shoot your gun with the controller
keep that aim steady literally and i
i'm still terrible at it but i'm better
than i was and that's enough for me
that's awesome let me just double down
back up for a second
i don't want to gloss over that that's
actually pretty cool and a pretty
huge thing you know i know you got the
art style
thing and certain things like can you
remember a specific
moment that captivated you and you're
just like
wow yeah i can i mean if when people ask
me well what did you see your friend
doing
that's a question i've had before and he
was driving around on venus
again in his warlock armor doing
something in house of wolves and
it was just oh and i i remember seeing
venus this beautiful
jungley planet with these ancient ruins
sort of from the vex
and just moss covered and something
about that really spoke to me
um and it continues to speak to me and
that's what i think i like about destiny
so much is the
you know i mentioned it already but the
the fusion between sci-fi and fantasy
yes star wars and lord of the rings had
a baby right you know it's what it looks
like
to me and that's really cool to me
because that's new because i'd never
really
been interested in um hard sci-fi or
hard fantasy
before that really separately um but
seeing the
merging of it and the coming together of
it was very interesting to me
obviously no i was like i mis i would
love
we're gonna get a tease of apparently at
some point but it's like i've the way
like we can get the screenshots and
stuff we can get now on pc i want to see
venus on pc because i would sit
and look out at that mountain with like
the blue like the lava flowing down
coming down yeah the rain and just
yeah knowing that if you took your
helmet off you your face would probably
melt
you're not wrong right you are
definitely not wrong
it's not right for me it's always those
sky boxes
it's just bungee your skybox and your
lighting engine what who
uh who let them do that honestly it's
amazing it truly is it
it all adds to it you couple that then
you couple it with you know this
great great tight gun mechanics
gun play and then just again which i
feel
never gets enough credit is the the
music you know
so it's just this great fusion of all
three of these things and like you said
you actually made a great point because
a lot of people we always talk about
guns and rightfully so
right the guns are amazing but yeah
that's what you cried for in the game
but
they've got yeah they don't get enough
credit for the armor design
just like somebody ornate let's talk a
little warlock
d1 end of d1 armor design still kicks
the crap out of everything we've had for
a while
that's 100 agree 100
i mean y'all are what the iron lords
podcast right yes
makes sense but yeah there are some
exotics that i want to come back just
for the way they look
and it's not all armor either like even
if you just want to talk about guns in
their own design too like
we could do that which ones which ones
you want no land beyond for me
is like pinnacle apex just this old
ancient like tank anti-tank gun
yeah it's it's just so cool
so it's rustic but again that having it
be
sort of austere and rustic in this
high sci-fi setting is it just slaps it
slaps
so hard what was the shotgun the
reloading shotgun
of its own invective yes i was like the
under
just the slight under yeah the orange
lava effect yeah like fire effect
underneath so it was not too much but
just subtle
yeah which makes it cool too right yeah
oh black on orange is always good
oh yeah that's good juju i mean we got
bad juju back super awesome
attached to it yeah which is still uh
that's one of the best looking guns in
the game or
helmets in the game for sure absolutely
yeah because titan's got some things
right
now you're good you're good you gotta
say 148 is iconic i remember seeing that
and i'm just like wow
that is a cool you know what i'll make
real quick decide how it doesn't get
enough lovers to tell you
i'm always like i was always jealous of
eternal wario but i don't feel like
trying
to selling it and no we don't like it
people love to meme on that helmet
because
if you don't have the right armor to
match it
it looks really good also don't put the
right shader on it it's just kind of
scary like it's just a little bit
horrifying
but i agree it can look really good and
it can have a lot of purpose i feel the
same way about
um they're new they're the promethean
spurs and people are like
oh weird toe shoes but like the reason
they're like that is because you're
like a grecian foot racer like that's
that's why they are like i i don't know
the exact i'm not really
um into that mythology as much greek
mythology but
like it's an athenian like sort of carry
the torch
torch run on bare feet you know that's
sort of aesthetic and that's that's why
they have their toes out basically and
that's why i like it i think it's cool
i think it's cool too i just wish it had
better functionality that's true other
than that this function is terrible
yeah the way it looks i'm like damn i
want to use it but why
what situation that was kind of like my
finisher bomb
thingy that it was like the same season
i think that one came out for the titans
not a fan of that one either so yeah
you're uh
what were the bombardiers bombardiers no
bombardiers is uh that's the hundred
dodge that one's actually
like i could see a little fun and now
the dodge bomb but no it's the
it's like the finisher explosion or
something like that the titans have
i'm not huge titans have yeah yeah what
is it
somebody will fill us in and check out
somebody's channel
this is why we have chat this is why we
have definitely
protocol maybe yeah i'd have to look it
up
hmm well joyce of joys of google here we
go
just now we just gotta know oh wait
crystal said a budget protocol
what is it a mercenary total protocol
sounds
probable actually
i'm not a fan i probably deleted that
actually so i'd probably have to go
digging collections or something so all
right so no way chris says no wait
come on chris you're supposed to know
this yeah what's up man
encyclopedia of knowledge
i'm gonna beat you nope are you a type
me ivantis yes i am yes okay
severance enclosure that's the one i'm
thinking of yeah you thought it was 100
i thought it was 100 okay
what's interesting been doing 113
episodes i'm glad they didn't pick up
any of those claps right there
it was all muted you know that's the
inside joke
no it says arc solar and void melee
final blows unleash a damaging explosion
finisher finishers and final blows
against more powerful targets increase
the damaging explosion so you have to be
in melee range to get a
pop so okay gotcha that's not a hard
thing to do if you're a titan
no we do run around and punch a lot of
stuff i am i am the right class because
even in pvp if i had my like
melee statistics they would probably be
much higher than they should be
because i probably crutch on the
punching
probably more than i should so i played
a titan
all throughout vanilla d1 actually i
don't know why
again it was a departure from the
warlock it's kind of life that i live
but
it was it's not disgusting
not at all it was just it was very
different for me and i i really enjoyed
it
i would definitely like to get back to
playing my other classes again for sure
i just haven't really had the time to do
more than one lately
so yeah yeah well final question from me
um as you mentioned planet destiny and
some may or may not know because
uh it's a pretty historic website in the
destiny community how did you
kind of get into taking that over and
what is your
i mean you're basically running the ship
but just kind of getting your thoughts
on
just like how that's been for you how
you got into it and just kind of what
you do there so everybody knows to come
check you out over there as well
sure so i started off with planet
destiny as a podcast host because
nem nem place actually got me into
the team and i did that for a while
and you know into the beginning of d1
and
christopher cyrus was a little bit rocky
for everyone
uh i enjoyed it personally i feel like
i'm the only person alive i started a
podcast
um i enjoyed that content anyway
regardless um
that was around the time the former uh
uh
manager runner for planet destiny
departed
because he had another job opportunity
um so we were left
uh it was very sudden too and we were
left with this kind of
um vacuum of
organization and stuff that would should
have been happening and
all this stuff so i managed to um
get into contact with the network that
owns planet destiny and say hey do you
want somebody else on this project and
they said yes
so here i am you took your shot and bam
yeah nice that's very cool like i'd like
to run the show okay
i thought that was gonna be a lot harder
now what do i do well i know
if you're familiar with uh the blacklink
tbl he uh yes
he he could have taken over he didn't
want to
at all it's just no i just felt like
i had the right skills and right
um i guess outlook for it so i felt
confident enough in that to
kind of pursue it and i you know i
managed to
get that position and yeah like i said
here i am
so nice nice nice that's cool yeah good
team over there like i said like
later i love my team yeah good good
squad
and it was good to see like i said you
know guys still continue that legacy and
tradition and
i mean it's it's still the iconic fact
that's like
it's still so much history i mean for me
you know as a
you know getting will be hood what's
going on what are you doing in here this
is a destiny podcast yes
absolutely that's the little brother
that will be cool dude man good people
um yeah so it's like
the thing about it was just like i
remember it's always been
a staple for me you know always seeing
what's going on over there as far as the
content stuff so
that's really cool that you took the
reins and leading this thing on you know
right
now i'm always i'm always down to let it
change and evolve and
you know give people an opportunity to
hang out and have fun with it because
it's it's more for the community than it
is ever for me
i work behind the scenes and try to you
know
try to help people out if they need it
and
give people a place where they can have
camaraderie
and help if they need it and resources
if they need it
so i i am truly i feel
honored to still be able to do this as
my job
and i deeply appreciate my entire team
for sure salutes that's awesome yeah
that's awesome that's awesome
yes do it no i'm good you got anything
else i think that was good
and referenced it actually definitely
answered my one of my important question
questions was that what's your class
that's all he needs to argue i don't
know what subclass are you then if
you're a warlock
all right no one's ever asked me this
pulled out yeah that's important i like
it
that's great because that that's like
the flavor right yeah
now for me i'm different because for d1
went straight to warlock but i did fall
in love with
sun cigarette first sunsinger's good
sunsinger is really cool it was the
grenades
and and then you know obviously the
super we knew what that was and i was
like wow
you you could die and come back just
like this necromantic
fire mage and it's yes that's so cool so
i
literally what
fix yourself sorry i had to fix my
throat there i apologize yeah
okay talk to me when shoulder charge
tracking is a little bit it
sucks are you kidding me it's not that
great right now does it don't
beg to differ it's worse than it was i
will tell you that it is definitely
worse than it was it
took a hit listen it is not glory
i'm sorry i just don't have a lot of as
a warlock who uses blink i don't have a
lot of vertical
mobility so i struggle with shoulder
charge tightens a lot of
what was the um little three shot melee
that i can't avoid one that like broke
the game for a while for you guys
controversial
controversy supernova handheld supernova
yeah you guys can kiss my butt with that
one
i never used it because i'm not attuned
efficient
so exactly
i've kind of was fronting on voice
like i just didn't play i was so
infatuated and i'll never forget
when i finally did this subclass is
superior like
like it's just better like it just took
me a while because i think i was so
caught up with the aesthetic
of being a you know solar world out
there when i got down with the voidlocks
that devour and getting your energy back
i'm like this is a sustainable
high purpose class once you master it
and then
blink was over there and i'm like oh the
neutral game on warlocks i think is
yeah really really awesome grenades
long-range melee and
for me i'll just remember standing at i
bought that's the
i'm staring at the title screen and i'm
looking at all three classes
and it was something about the character
holding the space magic
yeah yeah you don't have to tell me i
completely relate
i yeah that was interesting right i mean
because typically i would probably be a
titan in most games because i do like
the titan
you know went around okay again you know
what i'm saying but it was just it was
the little thing i'm like
he's special yeah
that's why he's got a little something
extra yes
a little yellow moon got my history in
there good i'm happy
thanks well that's it nothing else
happened this week related to destiny
it's been a great no i'm just kidding
so um in case anybody's living under a
rock we are in the world of online e3s
now
and xbox felt like trying to do their
second one and we got a little
distracted i think both cognito and i
did when
the destiny stuff came on in the middle
of being like oh that game's cool oh
this one's
this one's destiny i'm hello yeah i was
slightly destroyed
to my interests i was like okay eyes are
glued to the screen and it was straight
up a trailer about
stasis so before we cover anything else
xbox related we got a deep dive on xbox
or on sorry
kind of deep dive on the stasis powers
we got about a minute's worth of
gameplay related to
what they look like kind of some of the
supers in action uh very very very
functional grenade from the hunters i'm
very curious how that's gonna break the
game
uh but all in all just wanted to get
your guys thoughts on just the trailer
first from when you guys saw it the like
tease that happened in between and just
kind of your thoughts on everything so
far
so moon you are honored guest so you get
to go
first uh what'd you take out of that
stasis trailer just kind of
from the top ice powers
are dope i am just really excited for
like
you know you're talking about the
aesthetics of a sub class and
damn that is so cool literally hey see
what i did there
i just like that like that god
completely unintentional but i
i just you know getting to utilize a new
energy type and seeing what the
potential is for that i think is
really really exciting for me um and
also
if we'll see some weapons kind of play
into that as well
i am i'm very excited to see um
another thing that i'm always really
looking forward to is new destinations
getting to go to europa getting to see a
new enemy too
is going to be very interesting it it
feels it feels like that forsaken like
that taking king's sort of
promise again if you know what i mean
it's the big moment
yeah yeah so
excited yes very much so very much
yeah it was it was for me it was
definitely a surprise um
i think at first i was taken back
because i guess in my mind i had some
vision of what the darkness is
the darkness powers are supposed to be
yeah so that when i saw it i'm like oh
this is ice ice ice
like okay you know some freezing stuff
um
looked very cool um i got a chance to
only watch it like once or twice so i
definitely need you e to really break
things down i know you broke that bad
boy down frame my friend you about to
get in like
way too long way too many way too much
discussion
over single frames at a time yeah
people like the community analysts that
make content out of what they pick apart
i just
ugh hats off to you because i have the
attention span
of a goldfish my videos are not for you
you need the
stasis trailer in less than 60 seconds
that's what you need
okay i do like to look at things for a
long time i pick things apart visually i
think informationally i'm just kind of
like
oh i have to listen to this 18 times
before i understand what's going on
yeah it looks so cool you know we got
the trailer
i'm assuming that's a that was a
stranger i believe talking
during it most of it and i know for the
opening for sure yeah yeah for the
opening and um
i'm excited i think we got a little
snippet if i recall was it deep stone
crypt
oh there was a there was a shot or two
in the deep stone correct correct
at least if it matches the art style
from beyond light
from the actual website yeah if you're
excited for lore wise the deep stone
crypt is one of the most
interesting concepts in in the game
about it
you talk about you talk about it but
like
this is the source of the exos some of
the exo's sentience right
yes how neat is that how
like just cosmically metaphysically
interesting
is that to bring down into a story
that's you know
told through a video game absolutely
i am so intrigued i'm so glad you said
that because
for me again another we talked about
subclasses and all this stuff but
another cool thing about
about destiny again booting it up for
the first time was
human awoken and exo
and i was like now i went awoken but
i oh i was like exo this is interesting
like how are these
how do they have sentiments how do they
have and and as you play destiny you
learn more and
you know you cane and you know we got we
have so many
prominent exos you know in the game and
it's just
i just think it it's so cool that
they've added that and to learn the
source the history
and for me specifically doing the ace of
spades quest
you know hearing kate's history talking
about enslaves talking about all these
things like these horrible things that
happen like
how would they create what was the whole
process behind how they were created and
what happened so
look i'm excited you know there's a lot
of lord in fact that's gonna be the raid
too
like right i'm super excited diving into
that in-game
isn't going to be so rewarding because
typically they won't tell us who the
raid boss is they'll be like
hey who's the story campaign boss that's
going to be aramis we have the
very obvious like the raid bosses are
usually a bit more unknown outside of
taking king who we know
obviously was oryx for stage two
um i'm very curious to see who we fight
for one in the raid
and two like how that all comes together
for the deep stone crypt is there any
weird like bad exos or taking over
anything strange going on in there
that'll be really interesting oh
no there's so much so much potential
with this and like i said
one thing we all know september comes
around
and expansion time is always such a huge
addition to the game they always not
only it's a little later this time
well obviously yeah much later now but
in conjunction with something else we're
going to talk about
but um console but
yeah it is what it is so like i said
it it's just it's always an exciting
time and and just to see what they're
gonna have but the
i give them credit last thing i said if
i give it to you i
always am amazed as much as we give the
engine crap sometimes
shout out to titan oh no we definitely
have you know
you have to give them credit when you
see
i feel mechanics and things continually
added to this this sandbox right
like you get the game like wow an extra
subclass they added some classes they
added this they added finishers they're
added
each expansion they're just adding an ad
and i'm just amazed that they're able to
still
pull these kind of things off right i
think that's truly
what makes new expansion special people
talk about you know bungie's trying to
reinvent the wheel too much i
agree and i think if they did add more
mechanical details like that that would
improve the game in a similar way that's
not as
jarring to a lot of players absolutely
um at least that's what i understand too
from talking to people and you know
receiving feedback from
a variety of different guardians well
some of the best ones have been
taking king and then forsaken forsaken
was huge obviously because we got a
whole new set of subclass powers
and taking king we also did as well so
we've had these times where like our we
can have a whole lot of content we can
have different weapons but when the way
you play your character changes
that's the ones that tend to like sink
in as some of the best because it feels
so fresh typically
absolutely oh and another thing about
the new expansion
drifter heiress and the stranger as a
fire team
how cool is it
it is there i i made a tweet about this
a while ago but
they're you know they're especially
drifter and eris they're the outcasts
they're the ones that have been on the
fringes of everything they're not
because we started off with the vanguard
in this centralized little contained
bubble of what it means to be a guardian
and now that's
expanding outwards and i think that is
super cool
super interesting very very excited to
see how that will play out strange bad
fellows
exactly i just love the way she talks to
him in props he does
listen to rhett i'm like
and she should say it i love the drifter
with drifter's my favorite npc for sure
but
he is whoever's that voice we got to
find out who the voice actor is todd
happerkorn
is the voice for the director amazing
like i
literally laugh out loud every time i go
by the prison the recaster
like he's a fool
oh the narrative team i have so much
love in my heart for the narrative
narrative team i got to talk
i've got i've had the opportunity many
times to talk with uh jonathan toe
um who the drifter is basically his his
character
and speak to him about um this and then
this season a couple of other
um people from the narrative team worked
on the drifters voice lines i
unfortunately can't remember their names
right off the top of my head
um but they did such a good job it is so
fantastic the interaction that happens
between the characters
is part of what brings destiny to life
right
it's so good so good i tell people all
the time shout out to potassium we've
had on
and we're here with i i remember we had
a little tiff with the
the devil's ruin quest and i said no you
don't get it it was all about that voice
acting between osiris
saint and jax and i said i love that
quest for that
just for that like i sat there you put
the controller down and i just let them
go at it
he's like go just go about you say free
go free to go about the universe guard
those two are going to be at it all
night and i'm like oh this is great it
was so cool to hear the titans just go
at it
you're just gonna give them weapons yeah
yeah it's like
say it the crucible what have you done
with it
yeah yeah and oh osiris and saint um
is also jonathan toes uh a lot of his
writing is in saint
and shaq's as well and getting getting
those characters interactions too
wonderful it's again just it really
paints a picture and
individually they're all fantastic npcs
that
portray an archetype in a way that you
wouldn't expect
they they tell a story they're they're
emblematic of
you know the guardians themselves in
the way that there are certain
subclasses and classes and it's just oh
it's
it's all so good it's so good jeff kiss
jeff gets for sure so let me ask you so
like
got the big the big reveal happens you
know on the xbox stage we'll get into
the other part later but i gotta ask you
i know you didn't broke this thing down
a thousand times so
i'm i'm leaning on you for your great
knowledge
what did i miss what did you pick up
what did you get from this
uh two words hulk smash no i'm just
kidding
that is actually because we saw the
little tease of like what looks
like ice hands before i'm like what are
you doing with those and it's just this
little he pulls out the ice and smashes
into the ground it's like a wave of an
ice earthquake that travels out in front
of the titan
and i was like oh we actually get to see
it in action we actually get to see all
three supers in action so you do have
your hulk hands
i don't know if it's just a one-time
wave effect or
if we're going to have multiple types of
supers not entirely sure how the whole
skill tree is going to work for them yet
for the hunters we get to see their
pickaxes
or the ice axes actually thrown it looks
like a similar
whipping animation like the blade
barrage where they kind of jump up and
spin but you see i'm actually throwing
it at a
kind of new enemy race like new mini
scourge of scourge
boss like the mini mechanical guys are
walking around out there so i wonder
what's actually piloting those
and then we get to see the warlock with
the the lord of the rings staff
it's like stasis warp blasting or
something like that and he's also got
like some shots that he shoots out of it
so
we definitely got to see all three
powers which is very cool um
and again i'm wondering is this like one
tree is this going to be
like a variation of others are there
going to be three different options i
wonder how deep we get to see it for the
first time
i think the most intriguing part though
and i think everybody's wondering how
much it's gonna break the game
the hunter's ice wall slash shelf
warlock or
grenade and you get to see them in what
looks to be an encounter and he throws
it at the wall and he builds a new
platform i'm like wait what
[Laughter]
yeah i can only imagine the number of
people that are going to get places
they're not supposed to be
or somebody else said on twitter the
amount of like death barrier fields that
bungie is going to put around
everything to make sure you don't do
that because hunters are probably going
to break the game i think
but fun stuff oh yeah i did see i was
like what is that like so many
cool new abilities and again things that
they're able to add to this to this
engine and this sandbox is crazy so
salute to the team man i mean
they always come up with stuff you have
to give them credit of always kind of
reinventing themselves and
and adding new things to you know to the
game well the intriguing piece to think
about as well is the fact that we've got
stasis weapons coming
you have our solar and void damage but
you're gonna have stasis shields on
enemies stasis weapons that fire
are there gonna be stasis effects to
things because there's a grenade
launcher
that you see that almost has like a
little like lcd display on the side that
you get to see for a second as well
and i don't know if that actually has
any effect to it at all if it means
anything
but i can't tell if the grenade's just
like it's an arc grenade or if it's like
a stasis grenade because it's hitting
the little mini mechanical
fallen enemy and i can't tell if it's
actually freezing damage or anything
like that so you've got
the effect the weapons that are going to
be a whole different slew of weapons for
this
uh subclasses or for this elemental type
as well
um yeah yeah
yeah absolutely there will be so much
new stuff to just
mess around with come november nothing's
better than that new expansion feel
oh yeah oh you're exploring all the new
stuff oh it's great it's great i love
this time
so we're going to talk about that uh
announcement i was like there's more
oh oh my fault let me interrupt the
breakdown
a couple things for the races that we're
going to be facing obviously fallen is
in there we know aramis is going to be
we get to see truly a fallen catch
couple ships obviously the fallen
enemies
but then we also get to see what looks
to be more subterranean or a very
different section where it has
almost the pyramidian triangular
entrance and very much the vex
architecture is
split throughout the trailer between you
have a fallen catch that you're inside
of the fallen little
you know bays and domes and stuff but
then very much on the other side you
have the
vex architecture split between this
trailer so we're getting both fallen and
vex
and i was trying to think i was like
there's not a lot of times those two
actually
are in the same place right you don't
really see those two facing off against
each other
nessus i guess but like what narratively
has very rare yeah yeah right
so the fact that both of those actually
seem to be tied into it we know erimus
is bigger but his effects like
a subtle background or are they going to
be a major force in this one
that's a good point and then we know so
far from him that but he's like
trying to obviously reunite the houses
um you know they kind of
better consuming her excuse me correct
and um you know as far as like
accepting the gift of the darkness
because let's be real like they've been
kind of banished from the traveler
historically yeah the elixir yeah
did not have a good time i think that
makes them you know probably
one of the more sympathetic yes alien
races in the stories
their traveler just left them and they
just yeah they're ball back that's it
that's it can you blame them right
exactly like it really makes sense and i
i love this
angle that they're taking because they
would that alien race would be very
eager to be the recipient
of something that they've been you know
the opposite of what was forsaking them
so
yeah i'm excited about that i i'm dying
to see where that goes
it's fun this is fun i i really hope
narratively with all this stuff
the stuff i mentioned before and the
stuff we're talking about now that
bungie goes all the way with it and
doesn't just
kind of meet a compromise for
simplicity or something on the story
because this just
there's so many awesome threads too oh
yeah
travel down here absolutely absolutely
sitting on a ton
you're gonna eat continue i don't know
uh we also got a tease of what looks to
be like a
ice or stasis shrapnel tractor cannon
looking thing
towards the end you have okay first back
up we'll get to that in a second
you can shatter enemies now when they're
frozen looks like you can slide into
them
punch them ballistic slam if they're
frozen
they shatter which is like a whole
different type of finishing situation
because finishers are the thing i never
knew i wanted and i can't tell you how
many times i'm like oh i'm out of ammo
well i can finish them sweet let me run
up there and punch the crap out of them
which has been very very helpful but it
goes through and shows like
one you throw a grenade in it freezes
and i can't tell if it's an area of
effect or if they freeze by
proximity at one point uh and then also
you see just the titan come flying in
and just like shatter everything
in front of them so just the shattering
effect seems to be very very
useful as guardians to be able to
actually take them out
the wall that the hunters get that okay
we gotta talk about that
that is so the size of the wall because
they it's on widows quartz the map
and it's when you're going from the
cathedral like towards like the dead
middle lane up to where the heavy would
be sitting up on the perch
yeah towards the direction of b and they
throw the wall and it's
large i mean you could like run behind
the thing get up to a without even ever
being seen
so the fact that that's going to change
the landscape of pvp maps you're like oh
i can't get anywhere
hold on let me build a giant wall i
don't know how long it's going to last
how much damage it's going to be able to
take
but the fact just the way you're going
to be able to get around the map is
going to be
huge letting hunters control space like
that
is a horrifying concept
that is terrifying they're already hard
enough to face
and then land on your head which is what
they do and then it looks like the
titan or say the hunter that throws the
grenade
also has either one or two that they
throw i don't know if it's double
but they literally freeze guardian's
place i've been blinded
i've been poisoned i've been slowed i've
never been frozen
just completely shut down
yeah i'm kind of worried about that yeah
my main concern is actually pvp
oh i need to know how these things are
going to affect me
with dealing with hunters like they have
gotten
substantially uh more scarier and
the mobility aspect already they were a
problem as far as
very difficult to deal with but many
people who play on mnk
just oh my god i play on controllers
still but like
so i it's a warlock thing
easy i mean no no no it might be
because we're less reliant on mobility
so i mean it makes sense
sure i don't control the gang people
don't we got to take the slander from
them
now they can deal with it i'm not
pressed about it anyway
i am so sorry i keep interrupting no no
no no no
no we're good so i was kind of curious
though because we have
i'm wondering how the subclasses are
going to work because you have the
animation for the hunter that looks very
much like the blade barrage like
spin whip blade brush and it looks the
same for the axes now there's less of
them that throw even though they may hit
harder
so do you think it's going to be like a
stasis alternative for some of these
subclasses or do you think it's truly
going to be its own
tree custom tree anything like that
because again the warlock looks like a
nova warp but in stasis form
right so i'm wondering how far they're
just like kind of using some varied
animations with different effects on
them or if it's
completely its own thing because like
that looks like a void wall in stasis
like
the scale like what they use looks like
some of the stuff could be drawing from
other subclasses i'm wondering how it
ties together
yeah what do you think moon yeah no i
all i can say is that i agree i just
think it would look really cool i think
it would be really functional too so
yeah yeah it's going to be interesting
how it's
implemented right is it truly uh an
extra diamond like a subclass or it
should be
it should be i think it's i just think
it's about time for that
i would love it to be i mean and then
you know if it's additive
you know if it's that the case then my
question is like for example when we got
you know we have our our class ability
and
and melee you know do those change
because one thing i got to shout off
some hundreds right now
and this is warlock showing some hunt to
love right now i feel that
hunters actually need something that
helps the team
as opposed to yeah because hunters are
really
are you a useful tool if you want to
talk about the
your character like that for solo solo
engagement
tool to send
that's what the is is good at is
mobility is
solo engagement is you know sneaking
around pulling everyone through and
visibly stealthy
and utilizing your mobility to gain
advantage so
you're right it will give the hunter a
little bit more versatility
that's right because i feel for them in
pve
you know you know warlocks we got a
little recovery well or empowerment well
you know titans should throw up the cool
barricade and hunter just rolls
is going to sit there and say is like
i'm the invisible person that saves your
ass and rezzes you when you're dead
yes so it's like that's what they do
salute to that but i would just
love for them to have actually team
helping we know they're
soloist by nature but i would like for
them to help the team
sometimes with some type of it would be
cool they need that i really do
you know because shout out to last you
know was it last time expansion
i was so happy they got blade barrage
because i always felt i will say that
was a nice balancer yes yeah they needed
an
offensive you know shut down kind of
super
you know i always i always felt for them
unfortunately it went too far and now
they abuse it
you had to wait tights can't talk no i
was going to say like the main
if you ever play mayhem hunters are the
worst
okay but what other context is blade
barrage still that useful
i was really busted but
poking the hunters and they're just like
just just come to pvp we'll see you
there
oh no they they'd be salute to them in
pvp shout out to aries in this shout out
to the hundreds i'll see y'all let's see
here i just said pve i just want a
little support love that's what i will
say i'm i'm a pretty
hunterly warlock just for kind of the
vibe
aesthetic the aesthetic is cool i see
you i see you the hood
very cool yeah everything you do
mobility digging
triple jumps also can i say we have snow
tracks now
as they're walking through the snow
there's little tracks behind him in the
opening of the video i'm like
we actually have like deforming ground i
know i've had like footprints but i'm
like
it was actually like moving the snow i
was like could be cool
i'm wondering if there's any major
changes that come in the fall
and still technically fall barely fall
because we're like in
mid-november at that point when it comes
to this
next version of destiny 2 that's coming
to these next generation consoles which
we got confirmation
4k 60 and i'm just going to open this
for the xbox man of the group
beyond light on game pass
this is why i'm so happy your mic beats
you sometimes so i don't have to listen
to the light
in my ears it was perfectly muted for my
sake
he wooed but it looked like this yeah i
didn't i didn't get it either
nobody heard it give it to you there it
is okay
look um it surprised me i'll be
completely honest you know obviously
watching the um xbox game showcase um
it wasn't nothing nothing i expected i i
will say i mean
at this show i always said you know a
last word
that the relationship between phil
spencer and and ceo pete parsons
is super buddy buddy and as an xbox guy
you know i have phil spencer my friend
list the man
is 80 on destiny all the time like that
is his favorite game
yeah so yeah the man loves destiny he's
always been in since d1
so i knew the relationship was there the
issue came down to
you know in what capacity would they
work together because we know bungie
still likes their independence
you know since they especially since
they now you know breaking free from
activision they have creative control
but at the end of the day this is a huge
move y'all and the reason why
is you know game pass for all all
purposes it's one of the best services
in gaming as far as all the as far as
as far as value as far as everything
you're getting right
yeah game wise you know i know people
who were not interested in the xbox
ecosystem at all
they end up getting it they end up
getting game pass and they're loving it
but i cannot believe i'm spending ten
dollars or fifteen dollars
a month and i'm getting all of these
games now here's the key
destiny as an online service game
which definitely thrives off a play
account and population
this is going to be huge two reasons
one finally my console brethren because
i can't
i betrayed them for pc because that's 60
frames moon
that's 60 frames right i'm right there
with you you show me the light
and i betrayed my clan and i went over
here
i'm still yeah i'm still my part of the
clan but this is where i'm going to be
so over here in the penthouse you hang
out in the regular exactly
he showed me the light i'm having caviar
now i can't do
peanut butter and jelly eat sandwiches
anymore i like this this is what i'm
doing
those are extremes my god there's
nothing in between
so listen you just crap these consoles
by the way
so my whole thing downward is like okay
my console brothers are finally gonna
have nvme
right which is huge for ssd loading time
pulling up that destiny menu
loading into the planet that is the
biggest issue on console and to
get that situation figured out like
there's no problem anymore yeah my
brothers and nephews they have the
original ps4 which sounds like it's
going to take off with their playing
like god of course
i have the taken king ps4 still and it
still runs somehow
i feel like my mother will literally say
my nephews will
boot up destiny or go do something in
destiny play something else
while they wait yes
and like do [ __ ] on my phone until i am
loaded somewhere
and that's it i don't care about the
frames even as much as i care about the
loading times
the load was brutal so it's like shout
out to father you're the declare he's
like i'm
while flying into a planet and when i
came to pc i'm like oh i can't do that
anymore like oh the match started oh
damn like
i'm scrambling i'm used to going in the
kitchen bathroom
you're in it now yeah i have to play
quickly
so that's the first thing the second
thing
is 60 frames
per second right destiny is
inherently a different game
above 30 frames like playing you can't
play 30 fps
on pc like if you had to turn your
settings you just can't
do it if you're in now the question is
fov as well that's the other
changes the game completely like you
said absolutely but we don't know what
yeah
we don't know what consoles are going to
do for that one we're going to do fov so
i'm not going to get too excited there
but to 60 frames alone
prevents me from being in molasses
because that's how it feels like over
there
right again so you play like you get it
oh
4k hdr it's gonna be glory so and again
not only do you get beyond light
you get every expansion prior
like wow shout out to the cars going by
but
it's it's really impressive that
people who you put it this way you know
impressive shout out to willie hood who
was in the chat earlier right it's one
of my
um xbox guys really cool actually he
plays on all consoles
he is very lukewarm with destiny right
there's a lot of friends i know they
know how
hardcore i am and they're just not that
into it
people are telling me yo [ __ ] i'm in man
it's a game i'm going to try it
what like th the value proposition is
huge huge huge so at the end of the day
i think it's a big move you know play
account wise or population wise and um
you know
who's to say what happens with their
relationship moving forward but
that's a big deal because the way game
pass works
bungie basically basically how it works
is microsoft says hey
this is your your perceived value or
what you
we think you would make in sales if this
was on
our platform right it is up to them to
accept that financial offer up front so
bungie took the bag y'all
right yeah took that money up front so
that it couldn't be it's not exclusive
to the platform
but in the sense that the majority of
the game is going to be
majority people are going to play it in
that service as opposed to buying it on
xbox right
so that's the gambler they take but then
they look at a bunch of looks at it from
a player engagement standpoint
there's so many people now going to be
in that ecosystem and once you lock in
you tend to buy stuff you tend to be in
eververse you tend to buy a season pass
i mean that's the same
like they get the expansion but the
season pass they're gonna have to buy so
when it comes to them if they try it and
be like oh this is free oh
well i want to play the next thing now
you're gonna pay up and that's where it
goes in bungie's pocket and that's where
it's gonna keep them
invested both in game pass and giving
money directly to bungie so it's going
to work well for
you building the player base for sure
yeah huge value and for for
xbox i mean it's right around the time
the series x is going to launch because
beyond light comes out
now i'm very curious i got to ask you
all this stuff i'm very curious
that remember we went from september to
november and we do know they said it was
polish and stuff like that
it's very conveniently close to the xbox
series x launcher
you got to talk about it put on your
spin foil hat and see
i'm spinning i mean people said the same
thing about cyberpunk and
cd projekt red said it's not that so i
don't honestly put those two together
that's fair also i'm gonna say no
they're not related
okay if they had their choice they would
not be that close to
uh cyberpunk 77 if they had if they have
their brothers about it i wouldn't be
that close
oh what other game is coming out around
the same time too valhallas
if there's a call of duty's usually
november oh halo
delayed and then everything's going to
be fine actually but yeah
so but what did you think i mean i don't
know what
console i'm assuming yeah playstation 4
is what you primarily play right
on the console side but what just what
did you think of the announcement in
general
i i mean you guys have pretty much
said everything that was on my mind
about it it's gonna be
great for new players and to reach more
people and be
more accessible to a wider variety of
people
and new guardians you know that's always
such a special experience so it
makes obviously it makes me happy that
we're going to have new people in the
community and
people who are having that experience
for the first time
exactly exactly and then you know we
know cross play will eventually come you
know cross play
between system stays this year right my
understanding
so xbox you know one to xbox series x
platform family and playstation and xbox
play this looks bad
that's classic i won't meme you on that
you're good that was classy yeah
please please don't forget parallels
nothing to see here yeah
but we know the eventual goal for next
year is to um
really do true cross play you know
between uh sister and again like you
said boone
there's nothing more important for a
franchise than that player base
really being larger and it just brings
life into the game so
yeah just and yeah that's only going to
be possible with the
60 fps and blah blah so hopefully
hopefully it goes well
and i'm excited yeah absolutely e your
thoughts sir
oh just on all of this i mean it's just
exciting to see so we got confirmation
of like 4k
60 which means that's like what the next
generation of destiny is going to look
like on the new consoles which is really
cool
just hearing about what my nephews go
through for the loading times
if my brother can get a ps5 for them and
they can just like enjoy faster loading
times they will actually hopefully play
and get to enjoy it which is huge um
shout out to my nephews by the way i
literally was in the middle of probably
my solo prophecy run
when it like i was actually talking to
my nephew
in discord on his birthday so it was
actually kind of a cool thing but
um absolutely but yeah it's just i'm
really excited to
as you said grow the player base is big
because you have people get the chance
to be like hey what's beyond light it's
part of game pass let me jump in
and they say for as long as it's on game
pass i don't think it's gonna go away
probably for a while i would imagine
it'd be pretty stuck so people will get
beyond light and that's usually what
everybody wants to play and they'll
technically be able to level up
yeah as the seasons continue they'll be
like what's the new stuff and then
they're gonna hopefully venture out and
see what's going on
i'm just hoping it continues to help
bungie
grow because all we can see is you and i
have talked about this before whether it
be the tiger engine or the bandwidth
in what a season can handle or how much
can this expansion
put out and how much is the kovid like
put i would love to know more
about how married destiny is as a game
as
a thing that has to be designed and
developed to
the engine that it's made on yes what
would that look like
if they moved what is it the tiger
engine yeah if they moved off of it
like unreal 5 or something
that's something i'd love to learn more
about from bungie like i want to know
about how things work because that's you
know they get the producers and the
designers to talk a lot
about stuff and vidocs and things but
tell me more about the mechanics tell me
more about testing tell me more about
engineering and stuff because that's
super interesting to me
one one cool thing that we i'm gonna say
cool but one thing we
have kind of found out is you know
the unfortunate thing about the tiger
you know we love the engine for the
other things that it does
is that you know for the pvp community
who really wants dedicated servers
it's the way their infrastructure is
inherently
built is tied to it they have this
unique
mix especially with the um you know pve
and
the way they do um uh what you call
instances and space is the way
you know it is so there's some things
that us as gamers say like well why
can't they just like this is so all they
need
to do so much more to it than anybody
sees and i you know i'm friends
with some people on the test teams and
i you know the things that they talk
about and i get to hear about it's just
it's more than you ever
would be able to imagine if you don't
directly work on it because
right and and the thing is if they
change moon
you know do we get destiny in the same
fashion are they able to do
these kind of updates to like when
expansion drops up so
some things i think like you said
there's so much we just don't know
and as gamers we're all guilty of it
like you know
why don't they you know what's going on
here and stuff and there's probably so
much complexity that
i've done like you said i'm dying to be
able to just type in a couple lines of
code that'll fix your problems
developing that's what it is backseat
programming
everybody like 99 of people say that i
have no idea what's going on but i could
totally fix your problem
exactly exactly
but yeah i wish you i wish you moon i
would love
to pick the brain of those behind that
engine oh man
i mean everybody always jokes about the
spaghetti code and how one thing breaks
and
you see weird things how even just the
function of the game and i kept seeing
this in
wither horde you shoot the grenade out
and then you switch over to mountaintop
and the damage goes up so it's tied to
your slot not the projectile i'm going
how the hell does all this like
obviously the game is insanely
complicated we have no doubt about that
but you take something like unreal 5
that's built and you and i talked about
this before too is
how the gun feel is so specific to
destiny
like that's what makes the game what it
is and it's and i honestly we
like could they replicate that on a
different location right and that's
i mean it's unparalleled for me it's the
fps game that i picked up a controller
and went
i can probably figure this out that's
for a reason it's because the gun play
in
destiny and destiny 2 is so good and
it's you know it
honestly a lot of that is because it's
forgiving so yeah
and stuff and you're just like oh i have
carrots for hands or like it's just
impossible
potato potato yeah yeah
but it's it's why it feels so good and
i think that's part of its appeal yeah i
think so
and like you said the question becomes
if they go to maybe these better
looking engines so to speak you know
does it lose that feel does it lose that
classic bungee mechanics that we so like
the sky boxes are the same
so it's it's a it's an interesting you
know proposition and i know
internally they had to have all these
discussions before and stuff like that
you know me and e have talked about i
eventually we feel they might he's gonna
have to be a d3 eventually i feel like
there has to be
there has to be but you know we got to
see how iterative this engine
you know can go what do you think moon
do you think there's a d3 sitting out
there
after light fall or do you feel what do
you think hard to say
d3 ddr let's go let's know
i mean of course i have a hope if i
could be around for this franchise for
as long as possible that's
the ultimate goal i of course want the
games to continue to be good
and entertaining and playable and
enjoyable and you know
functional but it's it's just impossible
to say what comes next
yeah well i mean i will say this this
year
building into their plan of three years
in the future
this year's had an off season was
you know shadow keep versus forsaken
wasn't quite as big but the
story we've talked about before has been
building into
peermanships entering and then they've
setting up savithoon with stuff that we
have right now and that's sitting there
at 2020 who knows when that
things might be a little farther away
now so dates could be wrong uh 2021
and then lightfall the quote moment that
luke said in 2022 is
they've they've there's no question of
like hey this is we don't know what
story
no this is the story and they've got it
planned finally for years and we finally
get to see how that all works
that's probably the most exciting as you
said as long as the seasons aren't
you know we don't need more seasons of
unworthy and stuff of that nature
hey i'm stealing that from you
absolutely
i again i love the people that work on
this game i
know many of them but that season was
not very pleasant for me
at all and again i liked curse of osiris
so i don't know what that tells you
but i mean i actually really like
panoptis as
yeah yeah so we had like nps i wish i
had a little bit more control over the
damage in that fight but otherwise
like it was it was cool it was very
cinematic yes
that's what i live for really in this
game so
yeah those moments have been kind of
stellar but
yeah it's like the as we lead into what
the
fall holds for beyond light seeing what
the story does the deep stone crypt
somebody in chat mention like a k7 do
you guys want kade back or not just give
me a yes or no
i don't want kate back she was quick
i'm with her i have never been a cade
fan and i'll tell you why mine's a
different reason
i know this is a controversial opinion
i in game kade was never my favorite
especially in the beginning of d1
because i feel like
they took him from
this really complex figure in the lore
and a lot of his a lot of his
appearances were
it felt like used for advertising and he
just kind of
felt more reductive to me in the state
he was in the game like he was good at
making jokes kade was the funny guy
right like but if you look at kate's
lore we didn't get to explore a lot of
that
in depth and we didn't you know he was
he felt really one note to me in game
and again
i don't i once again
i love the narrative team so much so so
much but that's just that's a flaw that
i saw that is something i never vibed
with as much
and i i really do respect people that
love cade because
he is a hunter he is what it means to be
a hunter for a lot of people
and i that's really really super cool to
me so
but just for me personally kade was
never never never my vibe
so uh huh just forgive her forgive her
but
we respect it we respect that listen i i
do get your your point on this though
i felt i felt he this is my
you know analysis of him i love the
character
i do agree with you on one point though
i felt that
they didn't realize like how popular he
kind of got popular
and then i felt they kind of like used
him like as a marketing tool i agree
with that part
right and kind of just lumped him into
just
that right like you said and he probably
got so much more to him
but because nate didn't shout out today
to feel you know i'm saying that
really did not a good job and i think
what it is is that he just became
the comic relief at a point right
and he's much deeper deeper now oh the
hunters are saying like i hope she's
kidding
yeah i'm not i'm sorry like well here's
the thing but i love lorcade
i love you know you get to hear a little
bit about
who kade was before he was an exo we
explored that in game that would be
so cool if we got to see more complex
emotion and reaction
and growth i think from kate as a
character or just
change that would have compelled me so
much more of him
right and i that's that's what i mean
essentially so and you're making some
valid points because again
i think i felt unfortunately to know
more about him in his will in his death
he was actually
around and i was just like yeah you know
so
cedric said it's time for a hunter
rebellion to rise oh they upset
they're upset with boy hunter gang rise
up they like rise up
she's blasphemous but look you know like
that you gotta respect this she's
standing on it and um
you know at the end of the day has a
point in your chat sorry to introduce
you fozzie says kade six was a badass
he had a dark past he was killer i think
that's another reason because a hunter
is a cowboy
archetype right you think of k-6 you
think of the wild west that's why
forsaken had such
western vibes because but that's you
know that's the
ironic hero that's the sort of anti-hero
kind of thing
and that's i i agree and i wish we got
to see more kind of
complexity for from kade in that way in
game
yeah but to to your point e yeah i i do
agree with you like
i feel if look what would i be ups yeah
i kind of would be upset if he came back
because part of me is like
defeat the finality of forsaken that
it made forsaken forsake so to me you
just undead and then let's be real
that would be marketing lying because
they said he was dead dead
but people like oh yeah he ain't dead
you know no no he's gone so we're like
okay
they really mean business here so i i
would feel it would kind of be a
cheap money grab in a way
like to bring him bring him back yeah i
was like they use them as a marker
of it you killed him he needs to stay
dead because his death actually like
hit it hit you know whose resurrection
is going to be just
such a turning point for the game is
aldrin
we get to see aldrid again yeah
something yeah that if when that happens
in game that is going to be
something else and i'm excited for it
because me too
aldrin's existence as a light bearer
makes us as players ask so many
questions
we have to confront a lot of things
about this
reality that bungie's created with this
story
um you know should this person be
punished for who they were in a past
life do they remember who they were
do they know what they've done do they
know the implications of what they've
done and it's
no obviously that aldrin has no memory
of who he was
he could completely despise the person
he was
it's beaut that was one of their
signature moments
as a result of decaying death and i felt
it was great
story because now we're dealing with the
repercussions of that act
of avenging that's the only thing i give
zavala because of avenging this
kate you know and then we kill you know
this guy and now the light has chosen
him so it is such a cool
twist i'll never forget you remember
that day isabella's gonna be like
holding that quarterback
no no don't go like
the aldrin arc is so exciting to me it's
the story of redemption
you know you don't know what you did
it's a lot to it
and again like i just think it's cool i
i
i would love for that whole thing to
play out with the hunter vanguard i just
don't know when they're going to do it
but
i mean i'm hoping that's like seven
times yeah
but right now you know i've heard that
the narrative team again has
a lot more runway for their story than
they've had before in the past and
that's you know
getting to hear from them in any
capacity that's what they've been
talking about lately because they
they have this breadth to work with and
the way that we just have to you know be
patient i know it's
it's hard to navigate sometimes when we
don't get an immediate ending to a
storyline
and it's it's hard not to be like tell
us what happens bungie
but being patient and waiting for that
and then
finding out how that ends is ah
yeah we have an ending to we haven't had
an ending to many story lines yet so it
would be nice to actually see some of
these things like get a little
tied up with bows on the end of them
because there's a lot of just dangling
out there
yeah so they can start more just exactly
keep it going
we'll close everything up now and then
we'll go forward but i want to know
everything
everything tell me all the stuff exactly
so yeah obviously the big stuff this
week stasis trailer
can't wait that seems just like literal
game changing stuff happening there
uh we've got xbox game pass we'll hear
about playstation at some point i'm sure
it's going to be similar
and then in the 12 they gave us a nice
little deep dive coming up which is
stuff that i always love watching so we
got a developer deep dive coming up on
the destiny dungeon it's about prophecy
so we're actually going to see one of
the developer kind of deep dives that
they've done before breaking it down
i don't i i have not seen who actually i
keep being very curious because
i don't know if it's going to be art or
story because the story related to that
is really interesting because
prophecy and you've always got like the
wasteland where you see all the four
planets that are going away
i want to understand if they're going to
explain like if there's
because literally the word prophecy if
the story is actually being told to us
if they're gonna like
there's probably a lot they can't even
tell so i'm very curious what they go to
in um gotta toot my horn a little bit
here though let's go
let's go i finished my solo flawless
whoa
yes i was trying to do the first boss
last night and just
couldn't get past it so kudos to you
salute
so like honestly like when i started
trying to solo flawless i was doing the
first boss i was like i'm never gonna
freaking get this
and i have died many many times in
between to get there
so it was oh when was it i can't even
remember that it was the previous week
when i had like
i got to the final boss for like solo
practice
and i died on him for days literally
like get on for a couple hours work on
it die die
die die workout for days i was like i
finally got to the point where i
finished it and i was like okay finally
killed him
right and then i was like all right let
me start the next week went through i
was like all right so official solo
flawless maybe attempt to probably
practice i got him down to a
quarter health my first time i tried the
final boss to it
final a quarter health and died
stupidest little thing too it was like
used mountaintop on a scion i was a
little low i put up a wall
and he just did the melee like through
the wall with the reach and
those stupid zions in there why you have
to even punch them twice in the first
place i don't know i hate the silence in
those rooms
they're at power level with you yes
they're brutal
so that sucked second time i went
through
got all the way to the ribbons and just
like flubbed the sparrow drive
i was like oh i walk i walk in there
oh no i did the full floor and i was
like
no and i did the full flower and i was
like i don't care i'm driving it it's
happening
i did gangsta yeah so i drove it so i
had to
committed than i am to this salute
because for me
occasionally i'm just like i feel like
i'm gonna like hit the spacebar wrong or
screw it because you have a lot of
things you have to jump down and go
through to me is i'm like
if i can get by like two spots like i
know there's a couple places i do get
off and walk to like
transfer i'm not one of those that like
esoteric where he's like i'm never
getting off no there's a couple places i
could offer
two crucial transitions but everything
else like it's almost easier to drive
and get by everything so if i can manage
the two spots i was like all right so
we're going through
and i get there and then i finally get
to the boston like all right we're here
again
there is one room because it's a pure a
tetrahedron technically if you're gonna
get that's what all of them are there's
four sides to it so you have the base
one you start and you have three sides
that you could go between
and it's the one with the blue like
triangle that you can fall into
like the floor if you look up it looks
like a blue triangle
um and that's the one i hate the most
the way the room is organized they just
don't seem to find a good place and
it's always every time you enter one of
those rooms it's absolute chaos because
you got
three on each side and you have to use
like which corner do i start in i have
to clear one quick
uh so no to clear that thing i waited
for my super every time
took my bubble into one of those i was
just like i switched over to two pieces
of intellect gear and was just hanging
out with chat
talking away and be like
i am probably the stupid one who used
xenophage the entire way through
except the first boss i used sword
everything else i literally didn't take
xenophage off
nice my man i have been i love xenophage
i
it is the best weapon in this expansion
as far as i'm concerned
and i use it all the time and people
were like use mountaintop use this use
that
i am about to go back and or not
mountaintop uh wither horde sorry
right um i don't have a mountaintop i'm
not one of
the people who were committed enough to
get that thing i bashed my head against
that wall that's for real
but i just xenophage i love it and maybe
i'll maybe i'll have to try it because
it's it's so good it hits like a
truck it it it really does and for
high-end content
i mean having that now it's i mean yeah
i mean and then with snipers getting
nerfed you know izanagi kind of fell
down so
you know xeno and shout out to screaming
here shout out to wilhelm screaming i'll
never forget
that man dragged me i did not want to
get it because i was just like
it remember when it first came out it
was trash when it started
i was trying so i was just like and he's
like no bro we can get it real quick and
i'm like
all right he i went kicking and
screaming
playing with him to get it and then when
i got it and then like the very next
week they buffed it i'm like oh my god
thank you screen i'm glad i said i'm
glad i did this thing
it's amazing that's some of the things i
wonder though and i guess that's where
we talk about like the xbox and
what that does for the future or
anything like that when it comes to like
some of the testing we've had throughout
this year between lots of error codes
xenophage needing a 50
buff in pde like are you are you kidding
like how do you
how do you whiff the target that oh
it'll be totally fine
we gotta buff it by how much we gotta go
200
okay cool how'd you miss that far but
now it's
it is good and it can put out sunday i
wish it had like
like five more bullets yeah you just
want a little bit more
yeah if i put two reserves on him at 34.
now granted i'm using active mooring as
the titan so it just does its own thing
you never stop come on now you got yeah
you got a nice setup but i will say if
it was if you could do double reserves
and it was 39 you had three full clips
you can't get three full clips you
barely get like two and a half right now
i know it's like on purposes it's it's
so the reload is so
slow without something like actually a
more rig i feel like it would justify a
few more bullets in there that's
purposely done bro they knew what they
were doing the thing hits like a truck
it would be it would be really powerful
if it had anything else in its favor
yes and it does yes one thing about
bungie they do not like
us standing still and unloading on
bosses
oh i can tell you i didn't stand still
in that boss room for except tiny little
parts
bags but yeah that was
that was i will say of the three
yeah dungeons you've got all three
you've done solo three
prophecy is the hardest wow
i will say the other two so i said it
before like
so for the solos on the other two you
had shattered throne
bit of heresy pretty equal in the way
the encounters were you had like the two
mazes
up front like go through different
directions and figure out which order to
do stuff
you have kind of like a traversal
section you have a pain in the butt
like kind of chaotic section a little
bit more traversal and a boss
and that was like almost kind of what it
was going to be this thing flipped the
crap out of like so many different
pieces to it
in very cool ways first i added the
mechanic of the light in the dark so you
actually had to be more aware of what
you were doing just like
where your feet were standing and if you
were standing long enough to see your
screen switch over
and then it even just starts out with
the like the rotating rings like as
those move the light
in the platform moves and you're like
well crap i can't shoot dark back here
now i've gotta actually switch my
positions
and then just as you go through the cube
rooms you like teleport up and come out
another side and
you're and they're always just a
perspective in here it's like i'm so
curious to see with this developer
if they can give someone oh yeah some
like story narrative understanding of
what the hell this place
is in reference to the nine what the
prophecy is of
what is all these different things we're
doing how like it's
it's a really interesting design but
it's definitely harder as well
and then the boss room just to solo that
whole thing is
crazy at some point i do want to try and
work on like a solo
like build where it's like it's not
xenophage it's not mountaintop
now the goofy thing i will tell you guys
one time i went through and i finished
the first encounter
the circular salt and pepper section
i did that with mountain top truth
teller and a sword
that was it i finished it with just
those three on accident
because i was trying to be like somebody
was like what about what if i don't have
mountain tops so i was like i switched i
put my grenade launcher down there and i
had another auto rifle
and then i went to go put mountaintop
back on when i started again afterwards
but i left truth teller i was like yeah
let's see if it happens and i did it i
was like
all right there you go yeah it's like so
apparently it's doable and weird setup
so like there are ways but
i think the i think the force of having
to be active in many more places
makes the solo flawless harder because
the chamber of suffering
you have to be active but you can slow
down
even the ogre fight you can slow down
more than chamber of suffering but
chamber of suffering
is in prophecy like the intensity and
continual movement
in like three different places in the
data from prophecy so it's even
it they just cranked it up so i'm very
very curious about this
i'm very curious about this and you know
you love when you get these treats from
bungie from a developer deep dive
the thought process behind things and
you know i wanted to ask
moon this um one thing that really
struck me with prophecy
was how aesthetically like
it looked okay oh get it get it she's
ready oh
we opened it don't forget the can of
worms it's out there
let's go but oh my god my audio i'm so
excited right now
but i uh mm-hmm i hate to be like i know
people are punchy i know people don't
talk friends i am really good friends
with somebody who works i
don't know a lot of people really well
but there is a man named adam pino
peter we met we met him
awesome dude super generous like he gave
me my tour of bungie
when i was there last year
i'm not out here just to flex about it i
just i'm telling you i am
so just like i still can't believe it
because i'm so thankful
but he was like knowing you
and knowing how much you loved the nine
space because i
love unknown space i love the i like i
will sit and reckoning forever just to
look at it
so good um and he's like knowing that
and knowing that you like the elixir
it was impossible it felt impossible to
not tell you about it and i was like
so that tells i feel like that tells you
what you need to know is that this
aesthetically this is the dungeon for me
it is it's got the tron vibes it's got
you know the cube room
it's got the m.c escher sort of art
vibe going on it's it's so
in you have like the zen garden sort of
just kind of blank space
yes meditative feeling to a lot of the
areas and it's it's
it's beautiful it's aesthetically it's
one of the best things that's been
in destiny 2 in my opinion i agree i
agree
and shout out to your reckoning
reference too because
i i do love that you know it really it
really is cool and um it's just
something about that art style and the
triangles and little flags and it just
it's something about it
i and we got a shot again i'm always
going to salute the audio team
when you drop down and wrecking and the
beat hit that be hit different
where you know in the basement
sorry you
it's tough i like that recording in that
track you know i mean so for me
with prophecy it gave me a little more
of that vibe
more in this universe very you know
curious as to what's going on you know
the testing of the night
lore wise all this stuff is cool and i
loved it
it's so cool because i think what's
really really
wonderful about the nine space is it's
emblematic of what video games can do
with visual storing with visual
storytelling because you know this isn't
just a planet with foliage and stuff
it's
it's something that feels so out there
and so
unreal and different because you know
this is a medium that
allows for that and that's what makes it
really special to me
right well yeah you take even a lot of
places even somewhere like
venus you have you know different
colored rain and different covered lava
and like mars was like we gotta have an
aspect and you see something like this
and it feels
truly alien kind of the only other thing
that has hit
me that way is when it went on the
pyramid ship for the first time the
architecture and the feel in there felt
so i mean yeah you had a statuesque
figure but like the architecture and the
feel
felt more felt alien the nine feels the
farthest for sure
yes which is yeah so cool the nine are
the incomprehensible omnipotent
unfathomable entity even up even more so
now than the darkness because now we
kind of have a little bit better sense
of
what the darkness is and what it
represents but the nine are just this
concept that's you know in a dimension
that's not even our own it's it's so out
there
and that is them as like the guardians
of the galaxy like cosmics and two like
uh chris pratt's dad like kurt russell's
character just somewhat like
something so far removed that we can't
even fathom what they are yeah
celestials and stuff that's the word i
was looking for yeah i grew up on that
like i'm a big uh
silver server fan at marvel comics and
like i remember reading that book as a
kid i'm like this is real deep for
some of my like it's out there you know
saying but it
again it's again those type of
omnipotent
entities right and the nine just have
seemed to be always on the fringe in the
background whether it be observing
testing whatever they're doing
with us so it's going to be interesting
to see how they cue all this in
in connection with the darkness there's
so many story threads that they can go
and i'm very
curious to see where they go with it but
it's always good to get some
law or any little bit dealing with them
it's always right
and i always love you know i i often
talk about a series i want to make for
our youtube channel where i talk about
like occult and metaphysical
symbology and destiny because there is
so much
that underpins the narrative like that
like you get into
you know just your basic like mythology
your norse mythology with the iron lords
you talk about
your you know your greek mythology with
the vex
like that egyptian osiris and stuff
like that and what that all represents
and what that means and
you know the nine aren't separate from
this they're they're they represent a
lot of concepts that
um are present in esotericism and that
is something i love and something that's
i've been around for my whole life so i
would love to
get a chance to talk about that in a way
eventually that i can structure
correctly i see why destiny hits you
with all these different
yeah making complete sense based on your
history
why this game captivates you it makes
complete sense
it just makes sense for me i'm just all
all i can say is i'm hoping the game
gets a long enough life
for them to tell like so many more
stories tell all these stories that we
want to know about to understand like
will we ever actually get to even meet
the night and have any kind of
interaction with them
how far are we going to get with the the
light and the dark and all the stuff
coming in as you said
all the different correlations between
as you said the egyptian you've got like
the anubis helmet and stuff that they
tie between so many cool things that
they do
right and um uh crystal in your chat
mentioned the reckoning tarot cards as a
specific example of this and
i read tarot i do that in my free time
so that was very special to me
we got a question for you what's your
favorite d class
oh my favorite d d class i'm i'm a druid
through
i think that probably may make sense to
people
yeah for the animal yes like yeah the
animal skulls and the druid
yeah yeah yeah it makes sense yeah if
you played world of warcraft there's one
with your name on it so
you weren't good well there you go yeah
fast out the face
i've got to follow move on right now oh
thank you
she's she's fantastic awesome so yeah
that will be
tuesday 10 a.m basically at reset
they're doing the deep dive for the
prophecy dungeon so
i can't wait i will be i will be eyes
glued to
this is so useful i'm yes i spent so
much time in there
i loved all the dungeons because i got a
chance to talk to
eve campbell about shadow throne
uh she's the one who like helped design
that thing when like when you're talking
at the beginning
and i think it was she was the one that
told me that was like where you start
you're looking up to the end and well
the first time i went back in when i got
home and i was like
holy crap yeah you can and then it was
like then i noticed in profit and pit of
heresy you look
down and you can see where you and so
i'm like yeah what so it's like
you they couldn't do it here because we
kept warping everywhere so i did
like just those the dungeons are some of
my favorite pieces because
rating is cool i've always enjoyed the
rating part but i just haven't has that
good of a i haven't
had as much of a group to raid as much
recently i've had some more people help
me
which has actually been making a lot of
fun but the dungeons just some
challenging thing i can get into and you
have like
just the way it's all built the dungeons
are my favorite
light that's not the country just real
quick uh i
always get excited when a dungeon's
announced because i know how you're
getting here
because i'm like oh he when he heard
about prophecy because let's be real we
didn't think we were gonna get one right
necessarily
my worry now is we got one now that
we're not gonna get one beyond light i
worry we're not gonna get like a beyond
light dungeon i'm like
yeah it's the perfect pve content in my
opinion
because it's it's just between like a
strike and a race
right it's the middle ground between
those two it's accessible but it's
challenging it's
it's um it's doable yes
with a smaller team you don't have to
coordinate as much but it's still so
interesting and it presents a new
mechanic which again i wish bungie would
do that more and more things
oh and those so you get to experience
that i'm always going to be a raid guy
but i have to say dungeons are one of
the coolest things
additions to the game and yeah i i i
it's always a treat it's always a treat
to to see them add that stuff again
he was about to say something oh i don't
even know now i blanked wasn't that
important
i used your dungeon bag about my bash
video oh no yeah yeah
uh but yeah i'm just kind of very
curious to hear
about but yeah the dungeons for me and
oh that's what it was i was gonna say
and
dakota reminded me as well it's like
when i took my brother through
we can two minute work through and that
was when i actually got my flawless run
through
was by accident with him it wasn't the
solo flawless but the i because i was
like
helping him and i was raising him and i
didn't even realize and then my chat
occasionally like make me do like
sit-ups or push-ups like all right do
that
i flew back to tower and then all of a
sudden i checked him like oh i got a
triumph what is this and like flop wait
he's like oh no
and i did the flawless accident in there
and i was like but i got to like
experience that with my brother and
stuff so
it's been some cool stuff like that the
darkness has him he's back okay there he
is
yeah i saw the twitch drop for a second
sorry i couldn't
couldn't help it but yeah just the fact
that i got to take my brother through
and it's just he and i can play stuff
like that and it's harder for a raid
because
you know there's four other people going
on we're just kind of like making sure
we do our pieces but
my brother and i can play through and
it's not a strike like we've done enough
strikes we get them they're short
they're kind of
this is like it's a cool encounter for
both of us it's the right size as you
said
mm-hmm speaking of race shout out to uh
scarole you it
got my my god the salvation jacket yeah
looking like the top gun out here oh
jack it's amazing oh my gosh great my
first one i'm so happy
well then i saw moon got a got a book in
the mail that i'm actually very
intrigued to get oh god oh my god i
okay i feel like this is just
moon is like
a teacher's pet situation with bungie
because i've been
hyping up i got
they sent me the cookbook oh that's
fantastic and i almost cried when i got
it
because that works it was something i
really wanted anyway like it was
something i was like i'ma pre-order this
the
minute i can i'm gonna you know i'm
gonna
i'm gonna get it when it's out it's as
soon as i possibly can because that sort
of thing is really interesting to me and
getting to explore
the franchise the destiny franchise
through other mediums besides actually
playing the game
how [ __ ] cool is that um but anyway
so i got this little book in the mail
and i i like looked at it and i was like
oh
that's so nice and it just it felt so
good
and it was just wonderful it's a little
slow mm-hmm
all the chefs out there oh yeah yeah
anybody who likes cooking if you like
cooking you like destiny get this book
because there is
this guy there is a variety
of different recipes in there and
there's something in there for everyone
i think
after looking through it i am definitely
going to
make some myself very soon here there's
cocktails yeah i saw there's cocktails
in there yeah
there's i'll share one with you there is
uh it's
based on izanagi's burden and it is like
a sake cocktail
oh man i think it has mint in it uh it
just sounds so good
but yeah there's ramen um crystal's
asking if there's ramen
is there there's there's a spicy ramen
ring
really involved like you make you know
your
your broth that takes days it's just
it's so involved
um and like the the way this book goes
into the lore
and like plays with the game
is so cool a lot of the pages a lot
there's like a lot of little things in
it that are written from eva levante's
perspective like it's kind of like she
went around
collecting recipes and made this book
right um
and it's that's super cool and like
there's recipes in there that are
um kind of middle eastern flavored which
they talk about being in the tower and a
lot of people speculate the tower is
you know like people that live in the
tower are part of that culture and
it's it just it's such a deep dive into
destiny's
story it's 100 percent worth
getting nice i looked currently
unavailable i put my name on the mailing
list off to wait till it comes back out
it's perfect i thought you was day one
with that i didn't even know it was
coming that much and then i saw it drop
and then
yeah i just wasn't quite as on top of my
game yeah should have been
[ __ ] cooking videos so i'll work out
so you i'm like
i know you could literally do a channel
for that like this
boom this bed is a beast behind it
you could swing stash should talk
is beyond me believe me i know who
you're talking about i actually saw this
video over knives and stuff
i like to cook uh i do a pretty decent
job when i make some stuff
but now he's a chef like i'm
i'm a home cook he's a chef like i think
he would love
he swain one of the things i really love
about swine stash is that he is
passionate
about things and loves being around
other people who share that same passion
regardless of what your perceived skill
is right he
if you're excited about it you want to
if you went to sweden we're like let's
talk about
food that conversation could possibly
never end
like you could have that as long as you
stretched it out because
he just loves food and he loves cooking
and that's it's it's really cool so
yeah shout out to swainstash go follow
him if you like this video if you guys
don't know him definitely
little video about a chef's knife yup
got one of those
yes please for the love of god make sure
your knives are sharp that's all i'm
going to say on that
a dull knife is a dangerous thing bro
you would you know could you you would
have a dope channel doing that bro
well i was doing like so when we were
all so i teach i'm like a fitness
kickboxing instructor
but i still like food which is a problem
so i'm not a stint that's why i'm not as
thin as i should be
i hike all the time and i am i i'm
chunky so i get it
but but
like during all the quarantine stuff
like part of what we're doing is like
for our members at our studios
is trying to give them some content so
part of what i did is like cooking
videos and there's like a couple that i
did
for i think i put one or two up on my
channel i think dakota actually made one
of them they were like one was a
healthier recipe and stuff like that but
like the setup for cooking videos is a
whole different animal for like
real life proper audio i have like a a
cheap lapel mic that i got my wife so
she could try and make a yoga video but
i was like
i ended up using that crystal don't you
start
christmas time so it's like the cooking
like to do cooking stuff and again i'm
i hate making half-assed things yeah
right i get it
i was like so i want like i would want
like the dslr
camera set up with like a proper like
microphone recorded separate audio and
i'm like it's so much more of a
production than just this like amateur
thing
right um yeah the quinoa one is what you
mean you have to have like your cooking
tech accessible
too while you're filming while you have
lights on
set out beforehand i'm like all right
ingredients all measured here
everything's perfect okay
then i went through the explanation of
why i use these things
and then i'm like this is such trash i
ended up putting
i ended up uploading it dakota made it i
was like it was fine but it's like i
just
my production quality was uh so
low especially because i've watched i
mean uh the bon appetit test kitchen and
like all those i was like the
i know comparing yourself to that it's
like how could i ever because there's
something
hard on yourself though like he's just
like being ridiculous like come on you
got to start everyone starts something
i think you should i still think you
should i agree with you because like i
fall
into the same like traffic i can't
what is this i'm trying to remember
because i think nim's even mentioned her
too and i'm trying to remember the name
it's uh
she's got like the silver the rogue hair
for bon appetit and she does the
gourmet claire claire yes uh yeah claire
yep claire saffit shout out to claire uh
if i could ever meet her she'd
school me and everything she's she seems
so cool but she'll do like
she'll do gourmet makes and it's like
how to make a cheeto or how to make a
pop-tart and she'll make a
gourmet kitchen's version of like basic
she's made like
reese's cups and just like things that
you picture but it's a gourmet version
and it's just like watching her go
through breaking all that stuff down is
their kitchen is amazing but just all
that stuff is so so cool
no doubt well dakota said it it was it
was it was
fine when she did she was about that
he said dakota oh oh yeah
apparently i'm gonna let you guys talk
for a little bit
so if you wanna if you want to keep the
conversation or wrap it up
get a little play-by-play so mood as we
do here at the
the last part of the campfire we're very
promoting fitness here
you know we definitely had we got
sit-ups we got 10 set up sir get to it
so you know we like to promote healthy
my healthy body because that's what the
guardian needs even watching look at the
look at the proper form right here
this is textbook advantage right here
look at that look at the proper form the
elbows tuck the knees
this is what you want to do to really go
against this covert
stagnation you need to be trying to stay
active
you got to stay and this was what we
provide he provides
this you know crystal you're evil
and here we go i mean look at the
push-up form elbows out we're getting
the outside grip we're not doing this
right there you know he providing a lot
of motivation today
during these troubled times of no gyms
yvonne look what you get here at the
last word
[Applause]
bravo sir awesome good [ __ ]
i don't even know what you i don't even
know what you just said
i'll play it back later
the chat is impressed and you got a lot
of wolves
you know i got to give that play by
playing come on this cat you know what i
do
yeah salute to eve for being a sport
and salute to the chat for being crystal
for being pure evil i said i saw that
she had it coming too like i got some
points to you so i was like oh god
good thing you rose the points up a
little bit because they were getting
abusive before
yeah i bumped the levels up i was like
you guys are way way too liberal handing
out these exercises all right these get
more expensive now
you guys gotta save up listen the
pricing the price of the fitness
instruction has gone up y'all
this man does this professionally and he
doesn't hear on the podcast for salute
but uh yeah yeah it was it was it was
cool it was cool to see that
the cookbook stuff and just to see them
kind of get into that realm
um i love what you're saying moon about
the theme and you get a little
low and now i want it even more now like
i'm not just like
here's a recipe yeah yeah it's so much
more than just a cookbook
in my opinion and that's you know i had
a feeling it was to be in
it it definitely delivers absolutely
anything like a recorded audio recording
of like
one of the recipes and the lore that
goes with it just do that as like one of
your videos out there it'd be perfect
that would be super cool we got the
right voice for it so
yeah absolutely well thank you you do
they were actually saying it earlier in
chat just uh and very much enjoying your
voice it's very soothing
yes very very so that's radio that makes
me happy to hear i think it's
one of my better like talents or useful
assets
so that's dope
what you get yeah i was gonna well yeah
i'm coming back
so i'm good uh no that's most of it so
obviously beyond light we know it's far
away but we know it'll be part of xbox
game pass we'll wait to see what
playstation says which
rumors are that may be coming up not
that far away we'll see
uh but yeah that's most of what's going
on this week is just breaking down that
trailer frame by frame
yeah yeah i love that the beavers are
being handled so celestia that's true
yeah i will say did you read the thread
about that noise
that came out um let me see really quick
educate educate yes so they're somebody
who actually worked on the network
program
oh i'd like to hear this let's hear this
uh made a whole thread about it it's a
bunch of
technical stuff that i completely do not
understand but if you want to read more
about it yes
um his name is fletcher
dunn he goes um his at on twitter is
z post facto all one word
um but he talks about yeah just the
engineering that went into it and stuff
it's very very interesting
especially
yeah because the main issue was uh
brief overview not as much detail was
the idea is like there were different
servers that were touching
and it was like so you had chicago and
virginia which is central and east coast
and that's where a lot of the beavers
were happening
and apparently the issue was like if you
touched both of those servers it would
drop a packet
and would basically send you that error
so that was the major issue if it
if it happened to touch two of those in
its
pathing that was i think gener like
briefly what i caught at one point
and i'm sure there's much more detail in
it but it was just it's really weird
that they tracked
that down as a thing for a lot of beaver
heirs it's so crazy
yeah i'm looking forward on his timeline
you may have to send me the link
directly oh it's just a threat he was
talking in
okay oh yeah there it is i see it now
yep july 23rd
in reference to the code like the bug oh
he goes in
he goes really in yeah this is
definitely beyond my pay grade
yeah like if if you're into it in any
capacity
i am but yeah i'm more on the cloud side
infrastructure
oh gosh yeah he's he's definitely
network engineer
but yeah background for the fast few
months that's the game has been using
some steam peer-to-peer networking tech
that he's been working on
oh he goes in oh i'm gonna clip this
thread what i'll do chat
because it is very salute to moon for
let me know about this this is really
cool
i'll put the thread in the chat for you
guys that's the thread where it seems to
start it off
and e i'll send that to you too
internally so you have it
but i'm i'm a geek id geek for this type
of stuff so i
really want to know because um i've
always told people
you know people are giving me crap
because i was like look man this thing
was more stable when it was that
you know blizzard like you know well
they built it around that probably
right so i just needed to know as soon
as it went to steam
why are the animals coming out to what
work why am i like what's going on the
beans the centipedes and everything was
like it was crazy it would get to the po
it was so bad
i literally would get scared going into
the tower because it would take seconds
and i get
bumped right out and it was happening
consistently it was frustrating so
yeah definitely definitely going to
check that out i'll salute the moon for
that because yeah
that's cool stuff to see i always like
to see how the developers work around
stuff like that
and what the actual root and cause of
the problems were so dope stuff
nice so yeah let's uh
less damn building throughout our game
is a good thing
i love how they titled it damn beavers
so fitting of course
uh and yeah your twitch prime rewards
will continue so make sure you don't
forget about those
yeah mostly ornaments and such a couple
exotics that are very very old
but all of that all and all that pretty
much covers the week it's we're in this
weird limbo
limo's the wrong word we we have a
season that got extended by a lot
right uh so we're gonna have a lot more
time
for we said this before to where it's
how are they gonna space out the
evacuation of the planets how are we
going to wrap up if there is a live
event at the end of the season how are
the planets going to go away
but i feel like anything that was
potentially planned to happen is now so
much farther away we've got this
now big lagging window of what's gonna
fill it and we know we've got
you know solstice of heroes probably
going to the eas we don't know but maybe
and then now we've got the halloween
event which i have very low expectations
for
makes me sad because festival the lost
is another one of those aesthetic things
that
i think has so much potential they do a
great job in the tower when they
decorate those things but yeah the
activity itself is
like i've gone through for they changed
up it was like waves versus
did you get enough to get the five
bosses and i don't expect any drastic
changes this time especially as their
big focus will be beyond light
it's just we have so much more time to
do a seasons worth of stuff
and then we only have another seals work
on your longer game
is going to be the one to go for i will
say conquer right now for one shout out
to esoteric he soloed
the corrupt the corrupted grand master
he said it's the hardest one that he's
ever had to do
[Music]
even on the regular nightfall that
strike is
hell but yeah he said that one took him
about 25 hours of work and for him he's
like i will
i'm done he did it once and that's the
longest he's ever had and i'm just like
more power to you man
you're a god-like above pretty much all
the rest of us
he he's an exo he's not a human being
i'm at the point now
the level of of amazing things exoteric
yeah i like that i like that that's lit
that's lyrium excellent
he's he's he's he's he's that that's
that's an android that's something else
going on there
the level of baseball things that he
does is just like wow
but i will still say if you are going to
work on your conqueror title
still try it this season even if the
strikes got a little harder because sun
setting is coming in beyond
and if the conqueror keeps being a thing
your arsenal's about to get a whole lot
smaller so you may as well take
advantage of at least all your tools
right now
is all i can say so you've got and
that's again like
they did all six before and then they
opened up so you could do all six in the
same week for the last couple of weeks
are they gonna go same thing and we just
have like nine weeks to work on all of
them and they're gonna do two rotations
i'm wondering how some of the stuff is
gonna play out
yeah i mean it is interesting right
because we we
they had to delay which we we have to
assume
prior to that you know they had a set
cadence right
each week for what they wanted to do
with um
you know with this season leading into
beyond like so
it is going to be interesting how they
play the adjustment period
by stretching it out those extra weeks
so i am curious to see what happens
you know and we'll see see the cool
thing you know if you got other games
like
i do go to toshiba
and you've got really bad ghosts right
now oh my gosh
me and you're going to definitely talk
about that shout out by the way if you
guys are listening to this look for it
at some point a
last word uh who knows what we're going
to call that one but it's
we have both been playing way too much
of ghost of tsushima and we're
definitely going to be talking about
that one at some point
edition campfire ninjas cheetah style
embarrassing so we will do that but uh i
mean it's gonna be one
i mean in that defense we got to see
they may have some stuff cooking up that
we just don't know about
but um i will say morning i'm not
necessarily thrilled about you know oh
festival the lost and
you know these activities don't you know
get me jumping for joy
that i'm gonna be doing but you know we
understand the situation they're in and
you know we definitely at the end of the
day we want beyond light to be great
right so if they need the time take the
time you need
get it done if you got like you you said
it perfectly right
if there's things that you need done get
don't get your raids done
get you get your seals get all the
hardcore stuff you can done
and um you know prep what i've been
doing is you know i've been looking at
going through the vault
looking at my sunset weapons getting rid
of stuff that i need to get getting rid
of
the reprise getting the reprised
versions of things
the reissues of the same thing
you know and you know just having the
archetypes and stuff like that so um
yeah i'm definitely oh shout out to
chris chris was like yo if we're going
to do a sushi podcast
he's got that japanese law we may need
him for that
but yeah that's it that's what i'm
saying get things done y'all get things
done and um
you know be so you swear you're prepped
and you're ready to go
for the new content that's pretty much
it yeah
well i think that's most of what we got
for the week um
we can wrap it up i know it's we're
right at about two hours there for noon
so we gotta let you get back to your
world as well
but i wanna let you uh we could probably
talk about some of this stuff all night
especially if it's cooking and food and
yeah
forever if we get the right topics we'll
open you up but
uh i want you to let them know where
they can find you if you got any cool
projects coming up for
you planet destiny where they can find
you where they can support you
definitely check out her patreon so yes
tell them everything the floor is yours
where where is the best place to get all
your stuff
everything go yeah twitter is probably
the best place to find me
at moonvauld uh a lot of my personal
projects are kind of
in limbo right now my patreons and
just i am not doing a lot with that
normally there i
read narrative fiction and poetry out
loud and i oh wow
mail people letters and make little
handmade things for people um
but that will be coming back soon if
anything i do interests you you know
that helps support me a lot
um i'm gonna start streaming on twitch
probably at the end of summer uh just
moonvauld moonvault everywhere pretty
much sorry i got two of them on screen
if you can't see them but yeah
definitely
follow follow everywhere that you can
but yeah yeah for coming through
thank you so much for having me this is
an excellent discussion i
had a lot of fun awesome means a lot to
us yeah
thank you very much from from a fellow
producer of many things yes it
definitely means a lot to us thank you
thank you
well sir cognito of the ilp
what you got cooking i'm sure you got
nothing happening this weekend
nothing to talk about to talk about that
it's gonna be like a four-hour podcast
for you guys i can only imagine
uh no we're working on cutting that now
we get too long um
yeah so shout out to boot again but um
yeah you already know laura cognito on
twitter
i love podcasts on youtube and twitch
sorry mixer you don't exist anymore so
we don't stream to you anymore
forgot that was officially this week i
saw that tweet somebody's like
salute to the mix of lords that rolled
with us but you're gonna have to come
over to twitter youtube now and um yeah
but
it will be a fun show we're going to
have rand al thor
what if a big member in the xbox
community he's going to be doing like an
aftermath show hopefully
i don't want to jinx it but hopefully we
can get uh two special guests
one on the legal side and possibly one
on the um journalistic side in gaming
and i don't if it happens it happens but
i could confirm
rand will be there and rand is awesome
he's one he runs the xbox too he's a
great guy
so yeah we're gonna be doing the
aftermath of the most likely xbox uh
conference
thoughts fields all that good stuff and
maybe
talk about i think uh spider-man 4k 60
is might be a hot topic right now too so
far the miles morales dlc so tune in
sundays 1 p.m eastern
again on ironworld's podcast youtube
channel and again everybody thanks for
the support
for launchinggaming.net i really
appreciate it you guys retweet the
articles
you send a lot of love even when you
disagree with us we we love it we love
the interaction
so salute to y'all man salute to the
writing team everybody and of course
my brother king david if you are in
two statues these artistic pieces
please watch king of the statues and
it's on i love podcasts it's a playlist
for it
he's got great stuff up he's got an
amazing montgorial statue if you're into
marvel comics dc
he's got these iconic statues they're
expensive as hell but they look
beautiful
so if you hit that kind of stuff please
watch him he's so passionate he even
gives you a synapsis
of the character and stuff like that and
he did he did the evil thingy
i've been resisted to doing
buying and out he got me to buy my first
word out i feel so good it was an
impulse buy but i had to do it because
it wasn't
a statue yeah i can't spoil it now
because we plan on doing something
special together
nice you know with it on his oh that's
going to be so cute
yeah i know we got to do it with fab
because
he's like don't i got to be on that show
like you got to do it with me your first
one it's like your baby i'm like all
right all right
so yeah salute the king man he's really
killing it king david is absolutely
amazing
please follow that and like i said so
with the moon she's awesome i'm
i'm bonding like oh she's awesome we can
talk all day so much
he's awesome so salute to that uh
for me besides soloing dungeons in your
spare time uh
what else you doing sir uh i've been
playing a lot of ghosts of sushi most
you guys have
been seeing the streams for that one it
is fantastic the samurai
on i can't put that game down i wanted
to get the flawless
like solo files done so i could play
that so i'm happy it didn't take me like
all week to do
uh so i will be streaming that a lot um
i will potentially be working on
conquer at some point uh but also
potentially tomorrow i actually got
invited on another podcast
it's uh with james work so it's their
kind of saturday
warm-up so and it's on towards their
sunday potential guardian royale so what
i need from all of you that listen to
this thing
is tomorrow it is 5 p.m
central time i'll link it so if you
follow me i'll tell you guys where i'm
gonna be
uh but it's all based on like votes so
the more votes you have in chat for you
the quicker you move thing
move like forward in the rooms and stuff
and then if you get enough votes towards
the end you get to be on the sunday show
which is guardian royale so
wait a minute break that down like so i
gotta come up with tune in how does this
put on
you yeah tune in you'll like vote for me
and they'll like pull me in for the
quick interview first and that's kind of
how they'll kind of bring every
everybody gets to go in
but then depending on i guess how
everything goes then you get voted in to
be on like the sunday show
which is like guardian royale
like a podcast host edition i could get
some guys from pd on it
you could be on it we could get the
rezzo cast guys on it we could get man
yeah you could
maybe even like the old crucible radio
guys on it if anybody's interested
yeah what oh this is fire so yeah so
it's james work it so it's james w r e c
k no w e r k what's the format on the
rounds how long they have you
with that uh i mean like for me from
what like
it's gonna be a quick introduction and
you go over and he'll do kind of a
one-on-one with you when
once you get voted in and they're moving
everybody in there and then for the
guardian royale that's a separate thing
on another day so that might be a sunday
thing
which is the following days episode if
you and they'll just do like straw polls
to see who gets moved and stuff like
that
yeah we're going to be so that's me
tomorrow um so i work in the morning
come home do that at like five so my
wife's like bye
so i'm not gonna see her very much
except for about breakfast but
outside of that yeah so follow my follow
me on twitter
stay tuned for that one it will be
saturday 5 p.m central-ish times when
that'll be going on so stay tuned watch
me there
send the love my way would appreciate it
oh we got you bro we got you
real quick um crystal says that
la la monarch is going to definitely get
a catalyst now because luke said he
would do it luke smith said he would do
it after 100 retweets he said there's
now
400 retweets for lemonart to get a
catalyst
i don't even know i don't know what that
could possibly do
yeah that's a good a bow that's about
one of my favorite parts
i mean maybe what faster reload's just
terrifying i can't think of what you
would do for that what could you do
right what could you do if you hit them
longer draw time maybe yeah
it's the best i would agree crystal was
the best but i can't front though
trinity cool
friend of the goal right now is powerful
did you finish yourself can you imagine
if you didn't finish it i just i'm still
working
on a toaster so i gotta buy that but
yeah oh now he's sick yeah because i
remember i was doing out i got my
outbreak perfected finally
yeah you did i saw that congrats i
dropped the ball but you got the hell
out of good bro you dude he was busy
solo in dungeons
you you aren't a bigger fish you got
time to be dealing with me in this old
content
of a salute salute thank you um crystal
that's dope man i would
i would love to see that i like them
doing stuff like that because there's
some exotics that really need some
catalyst
so yeah more more destiny stuff tomorrow
without just yes
almost so it's a robotics yeah yeah
robotic katie she produces it and james
works as let's on his channel so it's
just a cool thing they do
great talented people wonderful
competent awesome people
and it's all for charity too so like as
it's going on the one that i was
checking out previously was for just
make a wish foundation so any
donations are going all towards that as
well so it's a good cause and a good
time so definitely check that one out
um and just two very awesome people so
both of those as well
but that's about all i got so uh moon
when we wrap this thing up i'm sure
you've
uh seen other people to try and do
synchronized things over discord so
it'll be fun
but as we wrap it up uh i'm gonna just
give the wrap and then i'm gonna leave
this giant little pause you guys just
say the last word joyce of editing i'll
smash it all together
but thank you guys for coming out uh
once we wrap up the podcast i'm gonna at
least have this channel raid somebody
else so stay tuned for that one
but for episode 113 i want to thank
moonvald again for being here it is a
fantastic
time to finally have you in here first
off so good that was such a good
discussion i'm very happy with thank you
uh we appreciate that as well um so yeah
july 24th we are wrapping this thing up
thank you guys stay tuned for the raid
and uh for this episode it has been
the last word